all right now to this story a family
torn apart by war in South Sudan is
reunited more than three years later the
three boys were living in a refugee camp
in Juba they thought their mother was
dead well we followed them as the Red
Cross flew them 300 miles to see and hug
their mother again Debora patta
is in Juba South Sudan with the
emotional reunion Debora good morning
good morning the mother of these three
young boys was attending a wedding miles
away when the country was plunged into
civil war her neighbor was looking after
the children in the capital of Juba
where they were forced to flee the
violence in the three years since rich
mat and gore last saw their mother they
have grown a lot taller today they
prepare to leave the place they've
called home since the Civil War began
when the fighting broke out the boys
sought protection at this UN camp up
north their mother also fled the
violence crossing the border into
Ethiopia the boys had no idea if their
mother was even alive until now they've
been living on the kindness of their
elderly neighbor it won't be easy for
naic pan young to say goodbye I loved
them as if they were my own she told us
in the long months when they yearned for
their mother soccer kept them going
who's the best at soccer they will miss
the local championships next month but
who cares when all you dream about is
seeing the mother you thought was dead
camera leshner she would carry my
younger brothers his 12 year old mat and
then she will hug us all his 15 year old
brother rich quickly adds and if my mom
has some money he says I will ask her to
send it to our caretaker to thank her
for looking after us there are lots of
firsts today the first time in an
airplane the first time in my wit and
the first time they are the center of so
much attention
their mother younger child reunited with
her boys we're gonna have to learn about
each other again she says it's been bad
but now I can be with them always
they're two older sisters cannot contain
themselves and it's all too much for
Matt just for a while it is time to
forget the horrors they have witnessed
today they can be children again this is
a story echoed across South Sudan
soldiers come in the dead of night
killing civilians and separating
families thousands of children have gone
missing and many more have been forced
to become child soldiers gale Wow
Debora patta thank you so much even if
you don't understand the language or you
don't understand the culture you
certainly understand the love and
emotion that those people felt when
they're reunited and they're the lucky
ones they yes that's right they're the
lucky ones that don't so many families
don't have bargaining very nice Thank
You Debra reporting from South Sudan
this more